well you know if we lived in a dystopian
future where our society's completely
collapsed and we need to live off the
land drew i don't know how you feel
about your survival skills but america
you are pretty darn confident the new
york post reports a new study found
two-thirds of americans say they could
live off the land if they had to or oh
okay
city dwellers were even more confident
than rural residents 72 percent of them
confident they wouldn't have a single
problem growing their own produce oh
no i no i mean i would look cute in
overalls and straw hat a little garden
hoe but
you are a garden house
you know me i
this i feel about this story the way you
felt about the catfishing story and the
couple who found happiness i'm furious
this is such bs we are all fooling
ourselves if someone took away our
iphone plug we'd lose our minds society
would be up in arms grow your own garden
self-sufficient we are the most reliant
incapable are you kidding me we would
all need a complete tutorial on how to
survive
i am shocked that this is your reaction
i thought you'd be out there with a
little butterfly net just scooping
things up you know making sure everyone
got fed who here honestly thinks if you
just got thrown in the middle of nowhere
to eat bugs and grow vegetables with
seeds you don't have
and figure it all out on your own you
think you're gonna be great
yeah no well listen i always i have
always had that little house on the
prairie fantasy you know what i mean
where i get a wagon and i plow the field
and
welly collects eggs and sells them to
the mercantile in town you know what i'm
saying
but but i know deep down that i would
just you know crawl into a ball and wait
till it was all over you know
i yeah i don't know why this that story
i i i like our reaction here i think it
would flip everybody out yeah and we'd
we'd be up in arms and in big trouble
for a long time but eventually the thing
about humans that i do love is we're all
cockroaches we all are survivors we
thrive we figure it out no matter what
we do not give up and if the last few
years haven't proven that nothing will
amen so
i
i love
humanity i love human beings i love the
tenacity but the flowery
we got this no no
a big adjustment yeah we'd be struggling
okay so anyway next um there's a new
water sport on tick tock and you can
play it at home newsweek reports the
water cup challenge aka the jenga of
water the aka water jenga is the newest
party game and you've already got all
the equipment because it starts with a
very full glass of water on the table
and then you take turns adding a single
drop at a time and whoever makes it
overflow first loses okay so you know i
love j like real jenga
um i could get into this what do you
think drew i don't know but we have some
here we're gonna test it out oh okay oh
[Applause]
you take a block from the middle
so
can i try first sure okay so does
anybody think they would be into
something like this
i gotta try it first does anybody think
they would not be into it
i'm the only one because i'm literally
like good moving on
[Music]
you